once a town of nearly 10,000 Bodie is
located just east of the Sierra Nevada
mountain range in California established
in 1859 as a gold-mining village at its
height there were nearly 2,000 buildings
here now 200 remain as this town lies in
a state of Arrested decay Bodie is one
of the most well preserved ghost towns
in America
you
Japan's Hashima island has a foreboding
presence you might recognize it this
completely uninhabited island played
home to the villain in James Bond
Skyfall once a booming coal mining
operation that ended in the 1970s access
is strictly limited but coming here is
like stepping into a time capsule
situated above the Arctic Circle
pyramidion is home to the ghostly
remnants of a Lost Soviet industrial way
of life frozen in time this now
abandoned mining town was established in
the early 20th century on the Norwegian
archipelago soval barred and was named
after the pyramid-shaped mountain that
looms in the distance
a walk through this place is a step back
in time to past Soviet glory remnants of
Soviet culture art and architecture
still stand today
it is predicted that due to the low rate
of decay in a frigid climate the
abandoned towns major buildings will
still be visible five hundred years from
now that's longer than any other modern
settlement on earth
deep in the Namibian desert is a place
time forgot
once a German colony miners flocked here
after diamonds were discovered in 1908
the town grew quickly fueled by the
enormous wealth hidden beneath the sands
but as the diamonds disappeared and
production relocated the town was left
completely abandoned to be slowly
consumed by the ever shifting desert
off the east coast of China near
Shanghai sits an archipelago of nearly
400 islands one of them is Zhongshan
Island a place where nature has
reclaimed what was once a thriving
fishing village
residents started leaving in the early
90s in search of areas where access to
mainland ports would be easier for
business and now lush greenery has taken
over the abandoned village
Oh
Paris without people know this isn't an
apocalypse this is Paris in China Tian
do Chang is a luxury real estate
development and a Paris look-alike
located in Hangzhou China as China
became the world's fastest-growing
economy real-estate developments popped
up all over the country some modeled
from famous western cities this Chinese
Paris started construction in 2007 and
while the city is built to hold 10,000
people only 2,000 live there full-time
making it feel more like a ghost town
the lack of people could be linked to
where Tian Yu chain is located
surrounded by miles and miles of
farmland the Eiffel Tower replica is
about one-third the size of the original
and stands surrounded by copycat French
architecture
and just like the original it's a great
backdrop for newlyweds looking for an
everlasting memory you know what they
say imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery
Cory is a very unique community
we have a million-and-a-half underground
residence and 1700 living residents we
have become the city of swords
my name is Pat Hatfield and I'm the
retired historian friends town of
Coleman
I've lived here now for 65 years since
1950 we have now 17 cemeteries I call us
the United Nations or cemeteries because
we have a cemetery for everyone we have
for instance we have four Jewish
cemeteries we have a Catholic cemetery a
Greek cemetery in Italian Cemetery
and we even have a bit cemetery we have
very famous people like Wyatt Earp and
Joe DiMaggio and William Randolph Hearst
and just goes on we inherited hundreds
of thousands of body because during the
gold rush so many gold miners came here
and with them they bought so many
diseases the San Francisco instantly had
27 cemeteries and they were full and the
city fathers said our lands be for the
living not for the dead so an eviction
knows was passed in 1914 and the bodies
were slowly transferred here to coma the
coma residents really respect our
cemeteries but we call the mark parks
that's what they are we picnic then we
walk in them are children playing them
they're just a part of ours we do have a
slower pulse here almost dead but